fast spreading fires burn everything in
their Park
Forest farms and homes
2 305 Fighters have been deployed to
control hundreds of wildfires
nearly half of them are burning out of
control
we are working on multiple sources of
forest fires that added to the weather
high temperatures and a lot of wind have
caused Great destruction both in
vegetation and buildings
fires began on Wednesday destroying
nearly hundred thousand acres of land
helicopters have been deployed but too
late to save some dozens of homes
more than one thousand people are
staying in shelters
I left my house with only the clothes I
was wearing there was no time to set up
a fire break nothing I think everyone
here went through the same situation the
wind speed changed very fast and
everything suddenly started to burn it
was all very fast Chile's government is
now seeking international support
we have spoken to several governments to
reinforce the efforts that were
previously being made with the companies
that provide the services these requests
include the search for equipment to
bolster the fleet of brigades that can
reinforce the work on the ground we are
in contact with several countries in the
region such as Brazil Argentina and
Uruguay
present Gabriel boric cut shot his
summer vacation his government extending
a state of disaster it allows the
military to mobilize to help battle the
fires as the number of dead continues to
rise